- All right, gov, I'm
skipping the intro today
and we're gonna max
out the time here.
This morning, President Trump
was on Hugh Hewitt's radio show
and Hugh asked him
about firing Fauci.
And Trump's exact quote was,
"You are not allowed
to fire him."
I suspect you probably
have a different take
on what you can do with these
civil servants like Fauci.
- Sure.
Well, first of all, it's
important to point out
for a long time, that
was not his excuse.
His excuse had been
that if you fired Fauci,
both the Democrats and the
media would've pitched a fit,
which of course is a
hundred percent true.
But that's the
price of leadership,
you gotta stand up
and do what's right.
Clearly he could have been fired
from the White House task force.
There was no obligation
to run him out
at press conference
after press conference,
have him doing media interviews,
you know, during the height of
kind of the COVID stuff in 2020,
Fauci would do local hits in
Florida media, attacking me
for having schools open and
some of these other stuff.
So there was no
obligation to do that.
I think you could have
also fired him from NIH
because he had basically
committed misconduct
with the gain of function.
You also had him saying that
it was naturally occurring
when they knew it
was a lab leak.
All that stuff has come out now.
So I think, yes, you fire him.
And here's the thing, Dave,
if it's the right
thing to do, you do it.
If they sue you, they sue you.
But you had the basis to do that
and you should have done it
and the country would've been
better off had he done it.
- So I wanna talk a bit more
about Trump in a moment.
But it does seem like
in the last couple days
that COVID is coming back.
Somehow they're
bringing COVID back,
or they want us to
think COVID's back.
Whoopi on The View
has COVID now,
Dr. Jill Biden has COVID.
Florida clearly is ground
zero for protecting the people
from government overreach.
What would you be
doing right now
for the rest of the country
if you were president?
- Cleaning out
the CDC, NIH, FDA,
all these agencies that
failed us during COVID.
We need a reckoning for what
they did to this country.
And yes, in Florida, we
fought back against it.
There were other states like
what Kim Reynolds did in Iowa
to make sure kids were in
school and to push back.
But there are parts
of this country
that were really, really
harmed because of the Faucism.
And yet they were
wrong about lockdowns,
they were wrong
about forced masking,
they were wrong about
school closures,
they were wrong
about mRNA vaccines
and yet nobody's been
held accountable.
And it's my view that until
there's accountability,
they're gonna keep
trying it again.
I mean, the notion that
you have a school district
in the DC suburbs, I
think Montgomery County
imposing masks in 2023 shows
that you give these
people an inch,
they're gonna take a mile.
So we need that accountability.
We are gonna bring reckoning,
we are gonna turn those
agencies inside and out.
We need people.
We don't need Faucis running
around those agencies.
We need people like my
surgeon general in Florida,
Dr. Joseph Ladapo, who was
right against the lockdowns.
He was right against the
force masking from day one.
That's what we need.
We need people like Dr.
Bhattacharya from Stanford.
So, I think they're
gonna keep trying this.
In Florida, we've enacted
permanent protection.
So you can't force
anybody to wear a mask.
You can't force kids
to mask in school,
you can't close
businesses, none of that.
We saw that this
would be something
that would likely
happen in the future.
And so we put in
permanent protections.
But that should be
the order of the day
throughout this country.
So, accountability
for what happened.
And just think about it.
Not only did you
infringe freedom,
not only did you lie about
things like vaccines,
the federal government went
additional $6 trillion in debt
over COVID with the response.
That's more debt
than we racked up
in like the first 200
years of this country.
And yet people don't
want to talk about it.
The only person that
stood up at the time
was Congressman Thomas Massey.
And he was pilloried,
but he was right.
So we are going to
have a reckoning when
I'm the president.
- I know you've tried
to take the high road
when some of these Trump
attacks are coming your way,
but when he goes off on
Florida and the COVID response,
implies that somehow New
York did a better job
or something like that.
I mean, do you want
to hit him harder?
I understand you're
running a campaign
and you're running a state.
But what do you think
the policy should be
on this sort of thing?
Because in some ways it
seems like a no-win situation
with the base to some extent.
- No, look, I think honestly,
I think he hurts himself.
Nobody in the
Republican base thinks
New York handled COVID
better than Florida.
Nobody believes that.
It's not believable.
And in fact, he
doesn't believe it
because he said for years
how good Florida did.
He said I was one of the
great governors in America.
All of this stuff
was kind of gospel.
Nobody ever questioned it
until about three days
before the midterm elections.
He saw that I was fixing
to win a landslide
and he started attacking me.
And then that's basically be it.
Just because he believes that
I'm a threat to his ambitions.
That's the only reason
he's saying this.
If he didn't believe that, he
wouldn't be saying any of it.
So it's obviously bogus.
I mean, half the country
visited Florida over COVID
and you're trying to
say California, New
York, and Illinois
handled it better.
Give me a break.
So sometimes I think, you
know, you should be responding.
But I think sometimes like
the more he does that,
I think it helps me
because I kind of wish
like he had broader reach
with some of his social media.
'Cause I think just putting
that stuff out there,
I think it hurts his
credibility more than anything,
especially because he's
on the record saying
how good a job we've done
in Florida in the past,
and especially because his
entire family moved to Florida
under my governorship.
- Yeah.
What's your message to the
ride or die Trump people,
like the hardcore mega base
that before all of
this they loved you,
but they're just
going with Trump,
but you know that you have
to get some of those people
to win this thing.
- Well, nobody in the United
States in the Republican Party
has delivered more
on America First policies
and principles than me.
If you look at immigration,
illegal immigration,
we've banned sanctuary cities,
we've cracked down
on human smuggling,
we even sent illegal aliens to
beautiful Martha's Vineyard.
And so we've put our
money where our mouth is.
You talk about
things like China,
we've banned the
purchase of land
by the CCP and its
affiliates in our state.
We got rid of things
like Confucius Institutes
and we cracked down on their
influence of universities.
You look at what we've done for
expand Second Amendment rights
with constitutional carry.
Look at what we've done to
fight against the woke agenda,
whether it's fighting
Disney involving education
or fighting this ESG movement,
which is really
bad for our economy
and for American families,
the way they're going after
domestic energy production.
You wanna talk about
draining the swamp?
There's one guy in
this entire country
that's ever taken action
against Soro's backed
prosecutors, and that's me.
And we've removed two
of them from office
in the last year,
year and a half
who were not following the law
and were putting their political
agenda over public safety.
I cleared out the election
supervisors in South Florida
when I became governor.
We've banned Zuckerbucks,
we've banned ballot harvesting,
We have universal voter ID,
and we even have an
election crimes task force,
police force in state government
which prosecutes voter fraud.
So we have the best
election integrity
in the entire country.
So I think in terms of
delivering on these things,
nobody's delivered
more than I have.
And everything I promised
the voters I would do,
I've delivered on and
exceeded those promises.
And so you've got a guy
like me going in there,
you know, you'll have
two terms of somebody
that the people in Washington
do not wanna see up there,
the corporate press does
not wanna see me up there,
and the Democrats don't
wanna see me up there.
Because they realize I
don't just say this stuff
in a campaign season,
when I tell you I'm
gonna do something,
I follow through and I do it.
- Is that the weird thing about
your campaign at the moment,
that in some ways Trump
and the mainstream media
are on the same side
when it comes to you
and that is some seriously
strange bedfellow stuff?
- Yeah.
Well, I mean, you know,
you were in Milwaukee
for that debate.
The night before the debate,
Trump's main campaign operatives
were whining and dining
corporate journalists
from NBC, New York
Times, Washington Post,
all these outlets that
he had always said
were the enemy of
the American people
and yet they're colluding
to basically try to
put dirt out on me.
And I think that
they've developed
a really unhealthy
symbiotic relationship
because the corporate press
wants Trump to be the nominee.
Partially 'cause he's
better for ratings,
but partially because they think
that means the
Democrats will win.
And they don't want
me to be the nominee
because they know
I will run Biden
ragged around this
country, beat him.
But more importantly than that,
they know I will actually
convert on all this stuff.
They want to see America
continue to decline.
I mean, that's what they want.
They don't wanna see
a guy like me come in,
reverse that decline and
put us on a better path.
So they're doing
everything they can
to try to shape the
battlefield accordingly.
But they work very closely
with some of Trump's henchmen
to put out as much
dirt on me as they can.
Now, the stuff they
put out is ridiculous,
but they do it and
they do it a lot.
And it just shows you,
you know, who they
perceive as the threat.
- Is it tough for you personally
to hear some of the nonsense.
I mean, I feel like I've
gotten to know you fairly well
and it seems like it just
kind of rolls off your back.
But when you see the
really crazy stuff
that he's throwing at you,
does it ever bother you
or the first lady or anything?
- I think we both
just understand
one, it goes with the territory.
Two, they're shooting at you
because you're over the target.
That's just the nature of it.
And then three, I think
some of it's so ridiculous
that I just think people
are smart enough to know
that it's a bunch of bull
and I think that they
just discount it.
They understand this as
political silly season
and you just do it.
Now, look, I mean, I think,
you know, there are some folks
out there online or whatnot
that kind of excuse
some of the nonsense,
whereas if the shoe
were on the other foot,
they'd be singing
a different tune.
But that's fine, we get that.
But at the end of the
day, what are we gonna do?
We're not gonna
fight the good fight
because we're worried
about someone may
say something mean about us.
I mean, what I always
tell people is,
in this day and age, when you're
standing for what's right,
it's not gonna be cost free.
Our country wouldn't
be in the state it's in
if doing what was
right was easy.
You go out there,
I mean, you have moms going
to school board meetings,
they're getting
attacked by the media,
they're being
surveilled by the FBI.
So leadership comes with a cost.
There is a cost to
standing for what's right
in this day and age.
And the way I view it is,
whatever I'm having
to do in terms of
taking that type of incoming,
that's not even in
the same universe
as what people in
prior generations
have had to do to
preserve our freedom.
And you can just see that,
just try visiting Arlington
National Cemetery.
You see people that gave the
last full measure of devotion
for service of the country.
So you're not gonna
see me whining
about somebody calling me names.
- Let's try to hit as
many big topics as we can
in the time remaining.
One thing that I keep
hearing from people
and when I was in Milwaukee,
a few people did say it to me.
They wanna hear you expand on
the Ukraine situation more.
That at first sounded like you
gave that statement to Tucker
that felt more isolationist
then maybe you pulled
back on that a little bit.
I know we have only a
certain amount of time here,
but I mean, do you wanna
lay that out a bit more?
- Yeah, sure. I mean,
what they said was,
I was asked after that
whether I thought
Putin was a good guy.
And I said, of course not.
But that doesn't mean that
we should be writing
a blank check
with no concept of
what our interests are
or what the victory is.
So we've been pretty consistent
actually on all this.
We need to end this
war, no blank check,
Europe needs to step up.
And anything we do should be
in America's national interest.
You don't subcontract out
your national interest
to other countries.
And I don't think it's
been in our interest
to be sending money
to pay pensions
for Ukrainian bureaucrats
and salaries for
Ukrainian bureaucrats.
So what I would do as president,
I would use the leverage
that we have available to us
to bring the conflict to an end
in a way that this isn't
gonna continue to be an issue
for the next 50 or 60 years.
I mean, just think with Biden,
his energy policy is
benefiting Russia.
It's fueling their ability to
wage war in the first place.
It's benefiting Iran,
he just gave Iran 6 billion.
What is Iran doing
with that money?
Partially they're sending
to Russia to help Russia.
China, he wants us to be
more dependent on China.
They're obviously
benefiting Russia.
So you can turn all of
those leverage points on,
but then also use the leverage
that we have with
our European allies.
Say, guys, this
is your continent.
You know, when this
thing comes in,
let's bring this
in for a landing
and then you guys
have to step up
and meet your
security obligations.
And part of what
animates that is,
I think our primary
national security objective
is to deter China.
And if we want to do that,
we're gonna have
to do a lot more
to project hard power
in the Indo-Pacific
than we've been doing.
I think Biden views the
top challenge as Europe.
I think he views China as a
client, not as an adversary.
I view China as an adversary
and I think they're the
only ones in this world
that could possibly compete
with us on a global scale.
- What do you make of the
polling data right now?
I know you don't
govern by polls.
I've heard you
say it many times,
but if we're to
believe the polls,
you know, somehow Trump is at
50% or something like that.
- Yeah, look, I
mean, I think that,
you know, some of these primary
polls are what they are.
I mean, you know, you
followed my reelection race,
there were polls that had
me up by one or two points
and I won by almost 20 points.
And so sometimes when you
have this volume of polls,
clearly polls are expensive.
And so if you're
doing them every day,
either someone's funding
that with an agenda or not.
But I also understand,
you know, you're
running against somebody
who is a hundred percent
name identification,
probably the most famous person
in the modern
history of politics.
But what I think that it shows,
and I think we have data
after the debate to show this,
is that, you know,
whatever he's at,
he's got some that are
very hard for him for sure.
And then he's got
a lot that are soft
and those are people that,
you know, they're willing to
support somebody that's strong,
that has a record of delivering
on America First principles
and that would be a big time
a change agent as president.
They are not gonna
vote for somebody
who's just gonna go back
and be a managed
decline Republican.
So if it's a choice
between Trump or that,
they're gonna go Trump.
But when they're presented
with my bio, my family,
my accomplishments,
and our vision,
you know, we do
convert those people.
Now, we're having to
do this on the ground,
going town to town in Iowa,
town to town in New Hampshire.
And we've actually had a huge
amount of success in Iowa.
I mean, if you look back
at previous election cycles
and find where the Iowa caucus
winner was in the summer,
people like Ted
Cruz and Santorum,
they were pulling
at like 5 or 6%.
You know, we're clear second
in Iowa under any metric,
everybody else is
in single digits.
And so, I wouldn't trade places
with anyone in Iowa right now.
I think we're doing
what we need to do.
And we are gonna outwork
everybody in those early states.
But once that starts to happen,
that's what's gonna
make the big difference.
So everything we're doing
is geared towards
accumulating delegates.
If we were trying to
juice national polls,
then, you know, we would
try to advertise nationally
and do some of those things.
And so it's a state by state
thing, that's what we're doing.
And we're happy with
the progress we've made,
particularly over the last,
I think four to six weeks.
I think we've solidified
a lot of support
and we're building.
- Do you want Trump to
show up to the next debate?
I mean, the last one
was a little bizarre
because you were clearly the
front runner at the debate
and nobody was going after you
and I bumped into you in
the hotel the next morning
and you said, "Well, they
knew I was gonna hit back."
And it seems like they
were sort of afraid,
you know, Vivek, a
little bit, I suppose.
But it seems like they
didn't wanna go after you.
So the dynamics are
really bizarre right now.
- Yeah, I mean, look,
I think he owes it to
the public to debate.
I think the idea
that he's entitled
to be nominated is absurd.
I think that there's
a lot of questions
that he needs to answer,
both about how he
would win the election,
but also about some
of the decisions
that he made as president.
You pointed out the Fauci
and then there are others.
So I think he should do it.
He probably won't do
it, and that's fine.
I'm gonna be there regardless.
I do think you're gonna
see a smaller stage
because I think some of those
folks aren't gonna qualify
for this next round.
And look, my thing is,
you know, as far be it
for me to tell anyone
who to run or not run,
but you either have
a path or you don't.
And if you don't have a path,
then we should focus
on the candidates,
you know, that have a
conceivable shot at this.
I will say, though,
being on that stage,
I think one of the reasons why
I wasn't necessarily the target
as much as people thought is
I have a record of success.
I've done the things that
people are talking about
that we need to do
for this country
in Florida across the board.
And so, I'm armed with the
ability to say that I've done it
and also to point out,
you know, whatever
shortcomings would be
from somebody that's
lobbying a grenade my way.
So I'm prepared to do
however it shakes out.
But if it's just me
and I get something,
I wanna look into the camera
and tell people my vision
of how to reverse this
country's decline,
beat Biden and get
us on a better path.
And I think we all know
we need to do that.
I'm the one guy
that has a record
of showing how it can be done
with how we've
transformed Florida.
- Let me ask you just two more.
As you know, I'll have
you on this show anytime,
but personally, I wanna
see you on the view.
I wanna see you sit
down with those ladies,
have them repeat that
hysterical nonsense.
Anna, what's her name,
who lives in Florida
and says crazy things
about this state.
Do you plan on going for those
fights a little bit more?
'Cause to me, that's
where you shine
and I think that that's what
people wanna see outta you.
- Yeah, we might.
I mean, I think we have done
some of the more
corporate press,
you know, with like,
the NBC's and the CNN's.
So you may see.
I mean, look, I think,
you know, The View,
kind of the hysterical
stuff that they've put out,
it can be a little
bit much at times.
But who knows?
You know, we may
end up doing that.
But you know, I'm out and about
when we do our campaign stuff,
anyone can come and
ask us questions.
We welcome that.
You know, we've got the
typical corporate outlets
that follow us around.
- So my last question for
you is gonna be for my mom.
My mom who is a
lifelong Democrat,
but she has woke up to the
insanity of the Democrats.
She knows how I
feel about Florida
and that I've supported you,
but the idea of voting
for a Republican
still in her mind is tough.
What would you say to that
person who's about to break?
They've had it
with the Democrats,
they've had it with the woke,
but the idea of really
making that move,
even though they part-time
live in Florida is a tough one.
What's the sales
pitch right there?
- Well, first I would just say
I kind of understand that.
You know, my grandmother
lived till she was 91
in Western Pennsylvania.
You know, her husband, my
grandfather was a steel worker
and she never voted
for a Republican
for any office in
her entire life.
And basically,
she was, you know,
traditional Catholic,
had conservative views
on a lot of things.
But it was like she said,
"Look, the Republicans
are only for the rich,
the Democrats are for
the working people."
And I would just say that
I think the parties
are really changing
in who they represent.
I think the Democratic party,
they're driven by
an elite ideology.
I mean, woke ideology,
ultimately that's something
that came outta places
like Berkeley and these
left wing institutions.
This is not like salt
of the earth ideology.
These are elites trying to
cram this down your throat,
trying to tell, you know,
your kindergartner daughter
that she's actually a boy.
That is not anything
that has ever sprung up
from kind of the
salt of the earth.
So I think what we're doing,
at least me as a Republican,
what I conceive of my role
is to represent
common sense again,
a restoration of
sanity in this country.
And to do like what
we did in Florida,
you know, you can't
please everyone, Dave,
but we took very strong
stands and we won 60-40.
I can tell you 60% of the voters
are not Republicans in Florida,
it's closer to like 36%.
So we had to get independents
and some discerning Democrats
to say, you know what, we
can't have an open border.
We have to have security.
We can't have crime
running the streets.
We have to have the rule of law.
We need an economy so
people can afford gas
and afford a home and
afford groceries again.
We need these core
things of parents' rights
to ensure parents are
involved with education.
Those are things I think
that span party lines
and that I think we can build
a strong movement behind.
And it's really just
restoring the country
to a sense of sanity.
- All right, we're clipping
that and sending it to my mom.
Thanks, gov.
We'll see you on the trail.
- All right, God bless.
Take care.
- If you're looking
for more honest
and thoughtful conversations
about politics,
instead of mindless dribble,
check out our politics playlist.
And if you wanna
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics, watch
our full episode playlist
all right over here.
And to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.